let's
go stop dude
I'm on the east side in the middle you
got a knife
pays him
a police involved shooting is under
investigation in Arizona after an
officer opened fire on a knife-wielding
suspect
the shooting happened on April 24th on
the north side of Phoenix just after 11
o'clock that morning a 9-1-1 call came
in for a man attempting to steal from a
business is that a house this is her
apartment
it's actually
a building
it would store is it then yeah with the
emergency
oh there was a side I was trying to
steal a small jacket from the wrong
store and he kept saying it was his and
I'm like no it's not and he is on a
green bike white male white
um shirts has a backpack and
yeah
probably in his late 20s is he still
there or did he take off yeah he's still
he owned a property riding his bike
around he's in the parking lot
yeah Midway through the 9-1-1 call the
suspect attacks the caller what color
jacket did he feel
s
if you did me what did he do
he kicked oh
and
off the property and you unappointed him
for hit kicking you
yes the caller then reports the suspect
is leaving the area and he's also
without
27th Avenue
yes
Phoenix police officers catch up to a
man matching the suspect's description
riding a bike in the area body camera
video shows officers calling for him to
stop but he refuses
you better stop you better stop you
better stop right now right now you
better stop
you better stop
that's right
the suspect then runs into a nearby
apartment complex where he leads
officials on a foot chase
get down right now right now hey he's
running back westbound
during the pursuit an officer spots a
knife in the suspect's hand
better stop
cool enough
the officer calls for the man to stop
but he refuses when he lunges toward
officers one shoots him with a taser and
the other opens fire with a gun
it's gonna stop you
I'm on the east side in the middle you
got a knife stop
pays him
this body camera video shows the
incident from the point of view of the
officer who shot a taser
foreign
police provided Medical Aid for the
suspect until the fire department
arrived he was taken to the hospital and
treated for his injuries investigators
on the scene also recovered the
suspect's weapon
the officer involved shooting is now
under investigation once complete will
be reviewed by the Maricopa County
Attorney's Office so far the suspect's
name in the incident has not been
released reporting for long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie